this is the photo that took one of my  eyes but gifted me with vision the  moment of death captured like a fly in  amber a life ends and a flower of flesh  and blood is born I realized the beauty  in destruction I was eager to share my  new work with the world neophytes  Philistines fools they feared what they  could not comprehend were determined to  stop me some consider this new world  horrific for me it is a world of beauty  full of pure creation that is lived by  my imagination  a world whose very fabric I can shape  but where can I go from here she is the  key the path to ultimate power  she is the brush blood is my paint and  this world is the canvas  my name is Stefano Valentino and art is  in the eye of the beholder